tom brady uh we don't know where he's
going to go right he may stay with the
patriots yeah it may go elsewhere the
more i think about it the more i think
someone is going to make him a gigantic
offer from a business perspective not a
football perspective and the patriots
will say we just can't do it right the
dolphins the dolphins are being coy in a
strange sort of way steven ross the
owner of the team said several weeks ago
he doesn't know why tom brady would want
to come to miami because the dolphins
are rebuilding brian flores who was with
brady for years in new england now the
head coach of the miami dolphins
he said i agree with stephen ross as far
as why would brady want to come to miami
i do i'll leave it at that i do agree
with steve and uh yeah why would he want
to now that doesn't mean they don't want
him right no that and look this is the
flip side of joe burrow here's a guy who
can pick wherever he wants to go right
and the dolphins are being very
self-aware being very realistic hey this
guy gets to pick any team in the league
why would he pick us now if he does
that's a different proposition right now
we don't explain would he want to come
here oh he doesn't want to come here oh
yeah no oh wait he does well well that
changes everything yes but that's not
going to necessarily send warm signals
to tom brady and his camp by saying
these things that the owner aunt brian
flores have said what what
we're rebuilding yeah you know come on
down here you know that's where i guess
i just i
i challenge that a little but if tom
reaches out to them and says
you know i i believe in you i want to be
in miami i want you to make me an offer
i want you to be interested in me i'm
telling you i want to come there i'm
telling you i believe we can turn it
around i'm telling you i've seen this
team and i see how it's developing and i
think it could be competitive within the
next three years i'm not looking for a
place where i win a super bowl today
this year right away then then uh that
that could change their thinking i i
just think that there is an opening
there sure for the dolphins to say
well if he does want to come here i mean
really yeah patrick yeah
who are you taking between the two yeah
i'm taking tom brady i know that no
there's no doubt about that uh i guess
the other thing that i just would throw
into that is just you know hey i don't
think tom brady wants to be a part of
something like that i mean we're talking
about the goat here we're talking about
nine super bowl appearances six
championships i just think he's gonna go
somewhere where he feels like yeah maybe
they don't win the super bowl the first
year but they're very competitive maybe
in the conversation
and i don't know how he's going to look
at miami's roster right now and feel
like they're quite there yet you know i
think this is going to be one of those
things tactically like we saw peyton
manning with the denver broncos where
you know yeah he picked denver because
he said man after evaluating that team
okay i like the coach and everything but
wow they got some young studs on this
team and this has a chance to be
something special here and that's why i
picked it and i think ultimately brady's
gonna pick a team
like that where he feels oh yeah i don't
know you know i don't know those answers
uh-huh you know i mean i i get you the
raiders are yeah you know a team that
are ascending in a positive direction
they didn't play the chiefs twice a year
i can't that with tom brady they're not
getting past the team winning that
division the path to the super bowl is
get yourself on a good team in a bad
division
run the table
force the road to the super bowl through
your stadium that's that's how they've
mastered it into it right i guess that's
team in a bad division that's why she
signed with the cowboys well that that i
like from that standpoint it makes sense
from all the other things you're arguing
except that that press has better than
tom brady and i wouldn't want to do that
than the cowboys but like hey i mean you
know
you know okay like let's just say a team
like the bears which i don't think are
going to be interested but that is like
that would make sense theoretically all
right you know we've talked about the
oakland raiders the cults you know just
from what you're talking about makes
sense you know even when you were in
crazyville with the 49ers conversation
like
like from tom brady's aspect that does
make sense to go to that type of team i
don't know i don't think they're gonna
ever get rid of jimmy garoppolo and make
that that kind of change but like i just
don't think brady's gonna go somewhere
and go i'm gonna waste a year to rebuild
at 43 or be a part of a team that i'm
not sure about i think he's going to go
somewhere where he's positioned himself
to where he really believes it has a
chance to be success and maybe that's
tampa bay too tampa bay could be that
team there's a lot of things right there
we look at we heard bruce arians
yesterday that defense is special they
got special weapons on the offensive
side of the ball at receiver that could
be one that if he's willing to go down
to tampa and live there that would uh
make sense
there was back in 2012
a belief that the one team that peyton
manning was interested in that wasn't
interested in him was the houston texans
they were fine with matt schaab thank
you very much how'd that work out for
them
i'm gonna be curious to see if we hear
that there are teams
that were that tom brady was interested
in joining that said we're not
interested tom whether it's the 49ers
whether it's the bears whether it's the
cowboys that's going to be an
interesting tweak to all this and it's a
slap in the face for brady so i don't
know how much he's going to want that
out there but you never know if he plays
really well somewhere and that team does
really well that's the point where hey
don go ahead and let it be known that
the 49ers said no thanks and that the
cowboys said no thanks and the other
team said no thanks
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports